welcome to episode 39 of the michaela
peterson podcast
i spoke with jeanette mccurdy in this
episode who i now have a huge crush on
she's an american actor best known
probably for icarly
she's a songwriter youtuber producer
writer podcaster
we spoke about her very strange life
growing up being a child star and
insanely famous
being stressed to death by that having a
very complicated to say the least
relationship with her mother
dealing with a pretty severe eating
disorder dealing with anxiety
and her current podcast called empty
inside which i also recommend checking
out
she was really cool i don't usually get
along with girls very well
especially right off the bat but she was
definitely my kind of chick
we spoke about my dad's program
self-authoring in quite a bit of detail
in the episode
it allows you to organize your mind by
writing out your past present and future
and because it came up i got you good
folks a code for 15
off if you're interested in checking it
out so that's code mp at
selfauthoring.com
and 15 off at understandmyself.com
as well for christmas new year's
whatever code
mp both of these programs i really do
believe in and believe are worth
checking out
understand myself does an accurate
personality test
self-authoring might be a cool christmas
gift uh or new year's
because it kind of allows you to
organize your thoughts regarding the
future
again that's code mp for 15 off at
selfauthoring.com and
understandmyself.com anyway i hope you
enjoy this episode
and if you do please remember to rate
and subscribe and thank you so much
to jeanette for coming on
[Music]
jeanette mccurdy welcome to my podcast
thank you for having me i'm excited
i'm excited too we have a bunch to cover
uh
so i'm gonna jump right in and start
with
you've done a lot with your career like
i think you're the same how old are you
i think you're the same age as me 28
yeah 28. so you've been you know an
actress a singer uh you've been on
tour you have your own podcast that's
like
a couple of things so you've done a lot
i regret most of those things
you regret most of those things okay
well we'll definitely get into that
um i wanted to start off with
maybe you could give us a bit of a
background of
who you are and what it is that you do
brief
we can start there yeah uh my mom put me
in child acting when i was
uh six and by 11
i was um successful at it to the point
that i was kind of supporting my family
and then by 14 i got like the role that
i would say
i became most known for on a really
popular show called icarly
and then there was a spin-off from that
show that i also did and then i did it
netflix after that so that was kind of
my career up to
23. it was all acting and then um my mom
actually passed away when i was 21
and that was led to an identity crisis
of sorts for me where i was realizing
well [ __ ] i've been living
can i cuss on this yeah yeah so i was
like [ __ ] uh
my mom wanted me to be this actress and
i that wasn't my dream and what do i
want out of my life
so i quit acting and began pursuing
writing and directing which is what
ideally i would like to make a career
out of
um and that's what i'm pursuing now
yeah so that must have been a weird that
must
there's a bunch to get into but that
must have been strange as like a
total kid um being the main money maker
for your family
yeah it was overwhelming but i also
think looking back on it
like without being like oh i'm trying to
find the silver lining i actually do
think it was really helpful
for me to learn that kind of work ethic
because knowing that like i had to
support the family was a help
well like i don't think i would have had
that much drive if i was just like
i want to act let me have fun or like if
fun was the drive i don't think that's
gonna get you to get as good of a thing
as quick at a thing as if you're like
[ __ ] i gotta put food on the table uh
yeah that's for sure
so i i know you i knew you you grew up
in a mormon family too right
oh yeah so how did how did that start
like how did your mom
get into you know putting you into
acting and how did you end up growing to
get as big as you are
um i mean i have i have complex feelings
toward religion i'd love to hear kind of
your thoughts on it overall as well
because it's just i think it's such a
interesting topic and something that so
kind of can be so fun to get into and
why people believe what they believe
and and how but um my mom
so my grandma grew up in eureka utah
which was like heavy
into mormonism so i guess she was
baptized but never
they never went to church were not
active remotely just baptized mormon and
kind of left it at the door
and then my mom got breast cancer for
the first time when i was two years old
and all of a sudden we just started
going to church all the time so
my sort of harsh judgment toward
religion or at least my family's
experience with it
is that my mom just like threw herself a
religion as soon as her life wasn't
going well in an attempt of like god
please help me
and then because she did have this
miraculous recovery she had stage four
metastatic ductal carcinoma the doctors
told her she would not survive
and she did and i think because of that
she thought well it's all because of god
so then she kind of like
threw herself even more into religion
after her recovery
okay that's that's really interesting um
my mom got diagnosed with like deadly
cancer
it was called collecting duct carcinoma
and she was given eight months this was
a couple of years ago oh my god
oh yeah it was i mean you've obviously
been there and your mom passed away but
it was like
it was not good and she miraculously
survived even though everyone said she
wasn't going to
um and she's found god so she's become
you know she was always like there was
always the idea of maybe going to church
and i think i went to church maybe twice
as a kid like
or maybe for a couple of christmases so
it wasn't a big thing we were more into
you know the stories behind the bible
and kind of the philosophy behind it
but more recently like my mom i would
say has
refound religion or found god uh and
that
really had to do with her recovering
miraculously from this cancer so
i get that yeah did you have any
experience with
like rediscovering religion because of
her cancer or is it not
not that way for you no like she talks
to me about it a bit and
you know if i get super stressed out or
obsessive about
something just like you know it's in
god's hands you know you don't have to
not control everything exactly but you
don't have to control everything
basically
uh that gives me more anxiety to be like
it's in god's hands like
can we put some [ __ ] in my hand kind of
that's kind of how i feel
it's like i get it you don't want to
ruminate about things you can't control
but but if you don't do anything
and things go badly like it's not it's a
little bit on you at least
right and then i think if you can if you
can give god all the credit does that
not also mean you can blame god
it's confusing to me how you're supposed
to give him all the credit for all the
good things but then also not blame him
for any of the bad
yeah 100 it also takes away
i find it takes away the credit like for
the effort you put in
right if you try really really hard and
you achieve something it was like oh it
was god's will and i was like
i i worked my ass off maybe maybe that
too and maybe they work together somehow
but
anyway so i've told my mom i'm not there
yet i might be
she was like gluten-free way before me
and
spiritual in other ways and i find
myself as i get older you know
gluten-free thing happened and then i've
become more spiritual but i was like i'm
not
i'm i haven't i'm not at that point yet
mom
can you can you define like what
spirituality is for you that's another
thing that i'm like i'm trying to figure
out what my relationship with
spirituality is it's something that i
want
it seems very peaceful and lovely and
i'm trying to like work through my
relationship with it
oh my god you're turning this podcast
around i'm supposed to be asking you
questions
no no no no it's good uh i've actually
become a lot more
uh i was really ill and becoming healthy
again
was very i don't really want to say
transformative but i had this one
world view and it was kind of
overshadowed with severe
depression and when that went away i was
it was like breaking free of that it was
it was a switch so spirituality i would
say
from being healthier i changed a lot and
then i've also done a lot of shrooms
and which is like the stereotypical way
people become more spiritual but i mean
if you do enough of that stuff you you
like you learn a lot about yourself and
you
i saw a lot and so that's really pushed
me in the more
spiritual direction like some of those
experiences so
i don't know if that helps you and your
relationships but i would say my
spirituality probably comes from
high doses of mushrooms you have to take
away shrooms i hope if we ever hang out
in person
maybe you'll be the first the first
person that i do shrooms around oh my
god i would be down for that
those are those are those are crazy
things you have to be ready
and you have to be in like you have to
be with people you know and trust cause
if you
you know go to a party you don't know
anyone there and you do something like
shrooms
like that is a recipe for disaster it
sounds terrifying
yeah it is it can be so i don't know
very much about mormonism and by very
much i mean
basically nothing so can you give me a
brief background about what that
uh religion is because i feel like
sometimes it's equated with other
religions that it shouldn't be sure yeah
i think the like classic
idea that people tend to conjure up when
they hear the word mormon is like people
with bonnets
working in fields of pay with eight
wives
um latter-day saints like modern
mormonism is not that at all uh in the
past that was like an old
uh custom i guess to try and get more
kids
out there they say um sure
but but now it's like it's very much you
marry one person
you get married quite young and you have
as many kids as you possibly can
um and then the it's a lot of like basic
christianity basic christian principles
i would just say it's like heightened
and then there are a lot more rules that
go with it like you can't have caffeine
you can't have hot beverages
oh buy anything on sundays you there's
just like a million and a half rules
that are very hard to remember and even
harder to
stand by yeah well so if you can't have
caffeine that would be no to alcohol
absolutely no alcohol yeah no um no
tattoos
no you have to wear garments under your
clothes every day
i don't know what the there's some
there's like reason reasons behind all
of it that i'm not
that i don't remember i just remember
all the rules because growing up with an
anxiety disorder it
gave me a lot of anxiety like oh [ __ ]
how am i gonna do all this and not do
that
yeah okay so how did somebody
so say your mom because you said your
mom kind of pushed you into acting
does that kind of how did that work with
being a mormon
that's a good question not well um but
my mom would find like my mom was the
master of finding justifications
for the things that she wanted to be a
certain way for example
like it was really shunned on in the
church
when i played a child prostitute like no
sister huffmire wasn't having it but my
mom
would come to church and like have this
testimony speech
written where she would then go stand up
on the stage and talk about how like
this is actually a really good thing for
the church because it might lead to
prostitutes
hearing the whisper of the holy ghost if
they see this and they know that
jeanette's mormon
like they might convert as well that was
the level of like
wow scream that my mom would take it and
somehow like looking back on it now it
seems ridiculous and absurd and over the
top
but at the time she would somehow like
persuade people
that that was reality and that that was
a good thing like she had a really
charming kind of side to her personality
um even though she was saying insane
things most of the time
well sounds like she might have been a
smart cookie to weave those kind of
things together
you know she had a capacity for
intelligence and i feel like it was
wasted and i feel like she didn't really
use it for good and it
it upsets me ah that's too bad yeah
so you have just going going off of that
you have this tour
or you wow you don't have the tour
anymore obviously covid
um but you were on tour and you were
doing a one-woman show
oh right yeah yeah um so what was that
about
i'm glad you were referring to this tour
i thought you were talking about when i
i had a brief
uh stint doing country music and i did a
mall tour and i thought you were talking
about
i watched one of those videos i watched
a video on youtube of a 2011.
it was fantastic it was so two thousands
oh it was great though i'm mortified
no i liked it it was like it kind of
reminded me of avril lavigne or
something just like
it's been a while since 2000 and like to
since the early 2000s yeah it feels like
it's been
forever yeah this year rose but you're
coming
it looks like you're coming back the
little loader's there there you are
um so so this this tour yeah i was on
i was doing a tour for my for my one
woman show i was just about to go to
new york for it and i was super excited
and that's sort of
the the place you want to go if you're
doing a one-person show
and then just i think a week before i
was supposed to go
covet happened and everything was shut
down i'm really hopeful that i get to do
it
soon things are seeming looking more
promising they have i think for a long
time so
we'll see and was that music what was
that
um it was a dark comedy musical
uh one woman show called i'm glad my mom
died and it's sort of about a lot of
this
material that we're actually talking
about today like my mom's influence on
my life and how she really
lived vicariously through me and i felt
a complete responsibility to live my
life for her which i'm sure was
um enhanced by the guilt that i had
about her
cancer and everything and then once she
passed away it was kind of me
rediscovering or discovering my my own
identity for the first time and not the
one that she gave to me
um and not the one that she wanted for
me yeah that's an intense story
was there was there anything good like
we
i want to get into the bad parts about
being in the public eye when you're
little because
it can destroy people like you you see
it um
from the sidelines so what were the good
parts
[Applause]
it's a long pause a moment of silence
um the good parts were yeah i mean i
think it did it did teach me
a good work ethic i think you know i
don't have to be
asked twice to do anything i think i'm
really self-motivated and driven
um and and then i and i made some good
friends i made some really good friends
and and also you know what i shouldn't i
shouldn't i think there's more i think
it's like
what i'm doing now you know writing and
directing is adjacent
and i don't know what i would have done
otherwise so so
who's to say but i do think that it's
helpful to have i
i already kind of have a somewhat of a
running start
on this career because i know well i
know the industry kind of works somewhat
like this
although it's very different as an actor
because as an actor everybody kind of
babies you and treats you like oh they
can't know anything because they're
sensitive and like nobody tells you
anything
um so it's it's sort of like an
it's definitely a more narrow point of
view i think to be an actor in the
entertainment industry but it's also
adjacent i think it was helpful
in terms of like switching to the career
that i wanted to switch to yeah so
that's fair
uh yeah what about what about the bad
parts that sounds easier
um bad it certainly is bad parts i mean
there's a lot of
um there's a lot of abuse that happens i
worked with an incredibly emotionally
abusive producer
um like i mean even talking about it now
my
my face gets hot thinking of it just
because you know he'd say things like
you guys won't
you guys will work you would work at
yogurtland if you didn't work for me and
he would just scream
how old were you i was uh when i started
the show was 13.
does yogurt land even higher people when
they're 13
is that even a reasonable thing to say
the real questions thank you
exactly it's like um he he was just he
was like
a comically like the bad teacher or
whatever you would expect in like
an over-the-top broad family comedy
that's what he seemed like very vilnius
and almost like mustache twirly in his
kind of personality um
so yeah so there's there's just like in
there's abuse which is a very on the
nose bad and then there's also i think
it leads to a sense of entitlement
um where it's like if you have so much
at a young age
you think that that's reality like my
reality when i was 13 was that everybody
cared what i had to say
my reality when i was 13 was that like
people were interested in me just
because i was on tv
not because i had interesting things to
say not because i was saying anything of
merit or
value and i think it leads or for me i
should say it definitely led to this
idea of like well
things will just be we'll just keep
working out we'll think well
it's like you don't have to try as hard
and formulate your own opinions and your
own point of view as much because you
just think well if i post this picture
and it gets 500 000 likes i must be
great
that's like let's tone it down you're
not that great sweetheart let's
get some interest in you but i mean
that's got to be that's got to be
difficult to understand if you have a
whole bunch of people watching you or
recognizing you
i mean when you went on this out on the
street i you got approached right
i mean it it got to a level that was so
intense it would just i mean there's
paparazzi and like
clusters of people any anywhere that's
like an act like a public
you know a restaurant like can't eat
without people constantly they it just
it for me it was really frustrating i
think i think for some people they can
kind of
i you know i don't i don't think
anybody's made for fame like i don't
think that there's
i don't think that there's anybody who's
made to thrive in it but i think there
are some people that are more able to
tolerate it
um and are just like better equipped
with their emotional and mental tools
to handle it and i don't think i was and
it just made me feel like i was going to
explode
all the time i was so anxious ah yeah
well having an anxiety disorder and then
being approached all the time
and being recognized everywhere sounds
sounds
anxiety provoking right not not a
not a recipe for success no and i find
i know that you know i remember i think
it was
eminem he came out with something and he
he got really angry at being approached
at a restaurant or something
and me as a kid i was like well like
that's kind of what you get
for being in the pub like i think
there's a level of
i don't i wouldn't don't want to say
like resentment or anger for people
looking in but they're kind of like well
you're a celebrity like what do you
expect
and then i know i've noticed through
mainly being around my dad
is and i'm not putting any negativity
there because most people who approach
him are really like really kind and it's
been overwhelmingly positive but it's
still like
you know sometimes when you're having
dinner it's like i just want to have
dinner
so sure it's weird it's a weird
situation
i'm curious about that too because like
with with you know your dad specifically
but i would imagine
like i mean he's changed my life i've
done this i've done his self-authoring
sweet three times i don't think
every year oh my god i have given it as
a gift to
everybody that i know i just think it's
so helpful in terms of like
getting you in check with yourself and
it's it's the most realistic approach to
like accomplishing your goals and
getting your life on track
that i've ever seen it's like why would
you know what i mean why was
i i just i i i want everybody i know to
do it
oh that's that's cool to hear yeah i
think it's so helpful
but um but so i i i would imagine like
if i saw you down on the street or
something i would be approaching him for
this thing that he's made
this thing that he's done um i
i presented fame i really did because it
was like people were coming at me
constantly for a thing that i was
ashamed to be a part of
um you know i was on a show that i
thought was trash like i just did i just
thought this is so shady this is so bad
i don't want to go onto this overlit
kids show set and like scream my lines
and just like whoa carly like everything
just felt
just so ridiculous um so
so for me it was like when people were
constantly approaching approaching me it
just
felt like god about this dumb piece of
trash that i don't even like
why is this like it just felt so i mean
i know that's super i think it's a super
unlikable thing to say but it really is
is my oh no it's just you know it's just
kind of sad right
um i get i think i kind of get where
you're coming from too because for an
actor too you're portraying
people who you aren't so then you might
be approached i don't know but you might
be approached on the street
uh from someone who treats you like the
character you're portraying
or somebody like dad wouldn't exactly
have that happen
sure sure yeah i mean people would come
up to me i played like kind of a
punky teen on tv a girl would bend a
juvi and at the time i was like
14 but seemed more like a seven year old
emotional like i was very emotionally
underdeveloped so people are coming up
to me and being like hey
sam like and i'm going hi like just
nervous and they're like oh you're not
cool
never mind oh man that's sad
that's all right that's all right uh
i've done
i did self-authoring once it takes that
it takes a lot of
self-discipline i would say to go
through the exercises because they're
not
fun per se and they're not frilly so to
hear you've done it three times it's
pretty impressive
yeah i literally have my i have my full
my
filled out ones in my drawer in front of
me because i
read them frequently so that i stay on
track i mean i take it very seriously
that's such a good idea so what are your
goals then what do you want to do
um i think i've done a pretty good job
my last ones were
like write a play was my first run i
wrote a play i didn't do anything with
it didn't like it
um better regulate jealousy anger and
fear that was a huge one that's hard
i've come
so far with that like they were really
[ __ ] hard emotions for me to regulate
before i just
didn't know how to handle them and i've
uh i've taken a lot of actions
therapy and whatnot to to try and get
better at them and
i've worked really hard wow wow so how
did you manage that those are hard i
think those are hard emotions for
anybody to regulate
yeah um yeah i i started a
therapy called dbt dialectical
behavioral therapy
and that's very specific to it's a very
like pen and paper therapy
and you um
yeah i i don't really know how to
explain it if you if you if you don't
know it but it's they give you literally
like a 400
page textbook when you first start to
kind of try to learn and that doesn't
mean
of course that like i still have i have
jealousy anger and fear
every single day i probably struggle the
most with fear or anxiety
um and it's they're still really
difficult but i no longer like do
behaviors that are detrimental to myself
or my life
because of those emotions now it's like
i feel them and they're painful
and i don't enjoy the experience of
jealousy or anger or fear at all
but at least i'm not making my life
worse when i have them
wow okay does that mean interesting
i don't know yeah yeah it does it does
uh i would say i probably have the
hardest time with
i'm fairly volatile uh have you done
have you done the personality test at
understand myself
no okay so he has i'm obsessed with this
test and it's not because my dad made
the test
i love it i used to give it to people
that i wanted to date to judge them
before i'd go on a date with them
as like a 19 year old um but it it gives
you a pretty thorough breakdown
of your personality traits according to
the big five
uh and it's accurate so it's fun if you
want to check it out or i'll send you a
link afterwards it's it's really
interesting
but i'm quite volatile for i had a
extremely severe depression
um technically bipolar type two so i get
the anxiety and depression part and
i still have lingering volatility
um just because i'm not very stress
tolerant like i'm doing good but if
something bugs me and i'm stressed then
i just like
fire off uh which isn't ideal but
sometimes it's entertaining hopefully
for me
i mean that's exactly what i'm talking
about it's like there's i i had such a
difficulty with emotions that i would do
things that were just like i mean it was
awful for
for myself for my life for people that i
love it's like it's not
it was not an adult way to behave and it
was really
i think painful for for people around me
and for myself
was really been too hard on yourself
though like how old were you
when when you had these the shittiest
years of my life i was a [ __ ]
monster of a person from 21 to 24.
i would say that's pretty young still
right like especially 21 to 23 i mean i
don't think
prefrontal cortexes are fully developed
in women until 23 or 24.
so you're literally missing part of your
brain
seriously and for men it's even a little
bit later so if you're just like why
does this guy only have half a brain
when he's 25 it's because
he kind of does
i i mean it's nice to yeah i feel like i
can't write it off though like i
definitely did think
because even even though i was 21 even
if my brain even though my brain was not
fully
developed i still caused pain i was i
was still cheating on people that i
loved just because like oh
i need attention it's like [ __ ] grow
up you piece of trash
like why could i not resolve a conflict
why could i not communicate my feelings
oh i'm feeling lonely oh i'm
feeling whatever why did i have to
resort to cheating and like what a slimy
[ __ ] i still think you're being too
hard on yourself
i had a pretty i had a pretty terrible
time as like a teenager up till
up till the time i actually got
healthier and changed my diet and
was less ill i like i did things that
i'm not proud of
but i can kind of look back on that and
think
if it's not something you would do again
you you probably need more shrooms one
of the things
one of the things they're really good at
and seriously
is they're good at giving you an outside
perspective on your own life
and giving yourself forgiveness right
like
that's one of the things they've really
if you're if you're feeling guilty for
things you've done and you're just
carrying that guilt
it does give you a bird's eye view and
you go oh man like she's had a really
hard time
she's trying really hard like you should
give her a break kind of from the
outside it's really helpful for that
wow it is just it's i yeah i have no i
have no
concept of it so how do you got to walk
me through this how it gets to
self-forgiveness
honestly i don't even know how to
describe it without doing it like i
tried
when my husband and i first started
dating i went to
some who was talking dennis mckenna was
doing
doing a talk on shrooms i think my dad
was talking or something or he went
there and i brought
andre along and dennis mckenna said you
know
people describe a shroom's trip as
life-changing or one of the most
life-changing experiences
of their life and andre kind of scoffed
and i was like you just don't get it
because you haven't done it
but it it opens like one of the things
it does is
your brain filters a lot of information
so if you're listening to someone talk
you know
you don't you don't hear the voices
around them very well
it kind of removes all those filters
so what it feels like is it feels like
you're exp it feels like
you're experiencing what reality should
be without filters
that's one way to describe it and if you
do enough of him
like you can you learn a lot about
yourself that you're
holding back like one of the one of the
experiences i had that was really
life-changing was i
identify i looked at every relationship
in my life
and there's there's a lot of
relationships there right people you
meet online like
there's a lot and i got told how i was
contributing negatively to those
relationships it was just like boom
reality
um so i recommend
especially if you need to like if you're
hard on yourself and you
shouldn't necessarily be because i get
where you're coming from for being like
a
young person and being shitty because i
i've been there
but you were young and if you're not
like that anymore
then it shouldn't be something you're
raking yourself over the coals
for in my opinion that's really nice can
i ask what do you mean when you said
like
when you say shitty what kind of things
um
well relationships not being faithful
lying um i drank
way too much oh same yeah
and that's not good and the thing is
there's got to be some sort of
like compassion for that kind of thing
too because it's really hard on
that person right like if somebody's
abusing alcohol
or cheating on people or sleeping around
that's really hard on that person so
they shouldn't just be like
raked over the coals for doing those
things because it's not like they're
having a good time
right right yes having a terrible time
they're having a terrible time and
that's why they're doing those things
okay so you had let's do let's do
another fun topic
you've spoken a bit about and i've read
some articles about you're experiencing
having
your experience having an eating
disorder
so what did that stem from
how did you manage to get that under
control what was that like
that stemmed from my mom
another surprise mommy she's back
um when i was 11 i i played
a lot of roles on tv that were like for
younger act like i played
seven or eight because i was very small
and
uh one day i felt like
a lump in my breast and i was very
scared i thought like oh my god my mom
had cancer now i have cancer i'm only 11
how can i have cancer
and i go to my mom i'm like terrified
and she goes oh no you're
you don't have cancer you're just
developing breasts and
the only thing that would have been
worse for me at that time than like
hearing that i had cancer was hearing
that i was gonna have breasts because
growing up meant that
i would not be able to pay my family's
bills i didn't my mom was always very
vocal about like it's good when you play
younger roles i don't
who knows what your crew will be like
once you can't play these younger roles
like we need to get you
we need to get you on a hot stream that
kind of talk
yeah um so i thought okay i said okay
well what can i do to
to not have boobs and my mom said well
there's this thing called calorie
restriction
which is anorexia um and we like had
it really felt to me like we were in a
buddy comedy like doing the hand jives
and then like
eating 400 calories a day like it it
felt like the happy montage in a movie
only it was this very sick and
disturbing
situation that i wasn't aware of because
i was a child i wasn't aware that my mom
was teaching me anorexia you know she
gave me stacks of diet books she weighed
me she measured my thighs with the
measuring tape to make sure that they
weren't yikes previous weeks
like very intense stuff um and i just
thought this was normal
and when she would tell me not to tell
my friends i thought it's because we
have such a special relationship
it's not it's not because she's doing
anything bad it's because like yeah
other
girls wouldn't get it because their
relations with their moms are just like
weak weird golden um
so that was where that started and and
then uh and i mean i've been through all
the eating disorders so anorexia for me
was
11 to 15. and then
um then it my eating kind of like
normalized i don't really have a
reason for why um i was on a show at
that time so maybe it was just like
knowing that i had kind of reached the
goal there was no longer a
career goal uh in my mind
and then um by 16 i got my period i was
very late to get my period and then i
went
back to anorexia because i was so
terrified of growing up again
and then um by 18 when my mom was
diagnosed with cancer i had binge eating
disorder
by 21 the year that she died i had
anorexia and then bulimia for three
years
and that is the end of that like that
was the end of my uh my eating disorder
history
that sounds unpleasant
in a word yeah totally okay so how are
you doing
now and did you get it under control and
how did you manage that
it's another thing that i tribute to to
dbt that type of therapy that i
mentioned earlier
um i mean i really think that that
specific type of therapy changed my life
i've never heard of that yeah it's i
mean i think cbt is definitely talking
about cognitive
girl and it's like talk therapy is
amazing and i think really
like for me now that's kind of that's
that's the game
that but but dbt was really needed for
like the extent of the issues
that i had i just don't think they could
have been resolved by anything less and
i needed to be a part of the program as
you also have coach calls which is where
you're able to call your therapist
any hour of the day or night when you're
dealing with your issues most
for something like bulimia when that's a
behavior that you need to really
be on top of like the amount of time
that i was calling my therapist to be
like i want to throw up i want i mean
it's crazy
it's it's it's impossible to
achieve that level of contact with the
therapist in any other type of therapy
interesting i've had a bit of experience
with therapy
well actually that's not true i've had
extensive experience with
therapy um
i don't like there was never a name i
would say was probably
cognitive behavioral therapy but a lot
of it was just
talking and it was a disaster every
single time
what do you mean oh my god so my first
my first experience was with this poor
woman i was
uh i was really sick as a kid
so i went to see her name was dr
lefebvre but
people called her dr froggy and she had
frogs all over her office and it was
already a problem yeah this is already
not gonna work
this poor woman she she dealt with kids
with physical
disabilities basically and i had
arthritis rather severely so i was in
that category but i was still
i was kind of i was medicated well
enough that i
wasn't in the category of kids with
severe physical disabilities like there
were
whenever i went in there it was kids in
wheelchairs
so i was actually less troubled than
most of her patients
and then her husband got brain cancer
and she just broke and this was right
when i was seeing her so
she ended up talking to me so that was
which wasn't great for like grade six
so that was the first experience i was
like i can't go in there like
her husband's dying brain cancer it was
horrible
so that was the first experience and
then
man there was like one therapist that
suggested my
like when you go to a therapist they're
not supposed to say things right because
you're very susceptible
when you're talking to people so if they
suggest things you have to be careful
because they can create false memories
and
this is a huge thing that happens so i
had one
and this was after i had my hip and
ankle replacement and she
got into like if my dad had been
inappropriate towards me as a child
and i was like i was 18 at this point
and i was like you can't just
ask those questions when i'm in therapy
there was no leading up to that like
where did that come from so then there
was that lady
and then there was another one that just
cried after i told her
like my hip and ankle place and she just
cried and i was like well
i'm not gonna go see that one um
so i haven't had very much success i've
had a lot of success like
writing down things that i can get out
of my head
and just getting them out on paper so i
did a ton of journaling and writing and
writing and writing
and that was very therapeutic for like
traumatic experiences
your therapy experiences sound awful and
hilarious
they're so good when they're written
down like they um i'm writing a book and
they're very good for the book
but for real life they were not ideal
right such is life i feel like anything
that's not like a fun life experience
it's like well
i better write a book because otherwise
this [ __ ] was just life
nah yeah it's less it's less fun that
way if i ever have something terrible
happen i'm like oh it's gonna make a
good chapter though
exactly exactly yeah i agree though that
i think writing helps
tremendously i think that's maybe even
more so than dbt i would say like
journaling you know again your dad's
self-fathering sweet but like just any
form of
any form of writing in a really complete
like
complete way i was gonna say word
vomiting way but considering my past
maybe
not the best that's a nice nice way to
describe it
kind of though a little yeah yeah that's
kind of accurate
if i don't know about it i might as well
word from it oh my god
wow well good for you for like getting
all that under control
i'm sure being under extreme stress as a
kid like is just gonna breed that kind
of
behavior right yeah you know actually
it's saying it now i
also think that quitting acting was
hugely instrumental like i needed that
for my mental health and i needed that
for my own
um my own self growth and my own
relationship with myself i couldn't keep
you know literally being people that
other people write and
you know trying to just the amount of
rejection that comes with acting the
amount of like wedging yourself into
these roles that are other people it's
like no i deserve to be myself man like
it's been enough
enough of being other people enough of
spending my life trying to be who my mom
wants me to be in producers and record
labels and like i'm done
and i think walking away from that well
i mean it was certainly the hardest
thing
or one of the hardest things i've ever
done the kick in the eating disorder was
harder but
but walking away from a career that
everybody's telling my everybody in my
family is going
don't walk away from this you'd be
insane to walk away from this you can't
why would you do that do you know how
hard it is to be successful at acting
what are you thinking and i was like
i don't know i feel like i have to do it
and and it was really hard but it was me
kind of taking a stand for myself and
i'm really glad that i did it
yeah that is hard because it's like
there's so much opportunity there it's
like how can you say
and especially if you're a driven person
and how do you say
no to that that's that's hard
yeah and and and and also because of the
influence everybody around i mean nobody
was like backing up my decision to walk
out nobody was saying like
cool doing a thing for yourself good on
you everybody was like
keep acting be a star
they all sound like yeah for some reason
they all they were all my agents
yeah that's that's great
uh okay it's interesting let me see
i asked instagram questions they had but
i didn't find no offense to anybody who
asked questions but they didn't have
that many interesting questions so i
kind of wanted to get into other things
you have a podcast empty inside
how did you name that why did you name
it that
um there actually is a song in my one
woman show
called empty inside it's a song about my
mom teaching me anorexia
and and i liked that title a lot and i
thought that it kind of
it was really appropriate to name it
empty inside since i'm kind of talking
about the opposite of that which is ways
to find fulfillment
and ideally through talking about like
uncomfortable topics because i think
there's no way to to get to any level of
fulfillment if you're talking about
surface stuff if you're talking about
just the sound bites or the press tour
answers you know you gotta get to some
place real ideally with whoever you're
talking to in order to
find a connection and fulfillment yeah
man that's kind of what i'm trying to do
right yeah that's that's yeah that's i i
really gravitated to your podcast cause
i was like okay she's
she's doing she's doing it she's doing
the thing that's so nice
yeah so you managed to okay you said
you're trying to work on your
relationships right
are you are you in a relationship like
romantically i am i am
in a happy relationship of four and a
half years and i actually
just gifted my boyfriend's sister the
self-authoring suite to bring in oh my
god
yeah she loved it and she's now in
college like it motivated her to
to sign up for online college she was a
ballerina she was a really interesting
story she was a ballerina
and her whole company shut down like a
professional ballerina and her whole
company shut down because of covet and
she was like [ __ ] what am i gonna do oh
god yeah
so i sent herself authoring sweet and
she was like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
apply what i what i know to and sign up
for some online college
that's so cool yeah if anyone listening
doesn't know about it it just kind of
helps you
go through your head and figure out what
you want and then
write steps guiding you towards that
uh in the in the least fluffy way
possible
i've read so many [ __ ] i was like i'm
way i certainly went through like a
self-help book
phase much regretted self-help book
phase and all of them
were just like what the f they're like
keep your chin up it's like how is my
chin up
helpful right like what how is that
going to help anything
am i keeping my chin ups going to write
a book cool thanks guys
be positive but he he makes it so that
you actually have to answer hard
questions
one of my [ __ ] favorite favorites is
that he goes what would happen if you
didn't do these things describe the
worst case scenario it's horrifying
yes yeah yeah necessary
you have to see both sides of it you
can't just be pursuing goals like i'm on
my happy like you're
denying reality if you're just
pretending like you're gonna achieve
every goal that you want by just
waving your magic wand at it right yeah
and it shows one of the my favorite part
actually probably that part is
it he gets you to list out what your
kind of bad habits are and then what
would happen if that's what you did
and then you see your future if you like
for mine i did mine when i was quite a
bit younger so i was drinking a lot
so that was my major one it was like if
you're drinking you're hungover and or
you make bad decisions when you're drunk
so it gets you to look you know i think
it's 10 years into the future
if you continue doing your bad habits
and it gives you this
horrifyingly ugly picture which is quite
encouraging
uh for stopping those habits it is
pretty handy
100 yeah uh so who
can i ask you like who your favorite
guests are how do you pick your guests
pic it's all through just like personal
interest if i think like oh this person
i like what this person's work first
it's like if i like the person's work
and then second if i think the person is
open and willing to be kind of
vulnerable because i think
you know there's just a lot of people
who are kind of more closed off and
and that's you know that's cool but uh
i don't know how to have a conversation
with that um
those are really just my two kind of my
two
check boxes yeah that's fair that's how
i've been i've been choosing
guests like half if i find them an
interesting person that i just want to
talk to
yeah or if i think that they're like
some people are misconstrued or you have
a
different idea of who they are then then
they actually are
so trying to grab some of those people
and then i do like health experts
to keep the keep the health aspect going
because it's been so transformative for
me
i want to shine more of a light on that
stuff like alternative health stuff
i love the idea of going of finding
people who
the public kind of perceives one way and
showing them in a different light that's
really interesting
yeah and you must have experienced that
fairly dramatically like i've had a
taste of these things but you were
totally thrown into the spotlight
so it's interesting speaking to you
do you have suggestions for people who
are like there was quite a bit of
interest in the eating disorder part
because that's something
people sometimes don't talk well if they
if they're actually suffering from it
they won't talk about it because it's
embarrassing and all these things so are
there suggestions you have to people who
are
battling that kind of thing yeah i mean
i
hate how expensive therapy is it's
really upsetting to me how
it's just like so not accessible for
most people
like okay you're gonna charge people 200
a session like what
are we talking about um here in the us
so
i i i would say if you can get your
hands on the dbt workbook
it's it's better than nothing it's it's
ideal to have a therapist kind of walk
you through
it but if you don't have that i think
that the the book itself the handbook
itself is
at least somewhat helpful um and then
uh and then of course journaling is huge
and i've never heard the word trigger
warning thrown around so much as in the
eating disorder community
but i think that sensitivity is actually
really counterproductive like i don't
think that you
you you can just go oh i'm not gonna oh
somebody's talking about a burrito i'm
not gonna listen
and hope to get better like i think you
have to hear
thoughtful conversations about eating
disorders and about people who have had
eating disorders the good the bad and
the ugly
you you can't deny that there's some
sort of positive reinforcement from
having one or
like nobody would have any disorder if
there wasn't some positive reinforcement
to them
right so you can't just pretend like
it's this ugly big bad wolf
and then i think the you have to
acknowledge the bad as well so that you
really know what your future is going to
be like if you
if you continue i you know continue down
the path
yeah uh there are a lot of triggers
speaking of trigger warnings and where
you wouldn't
necessarily expect them i had a kid when
i was like
fairly young nowadays so 24
and i joined a couple of mothers groups
because i was like i need some mom
friends all my friends are drinking
uh and there were so many trigger
warnings you couldn't communicate with
anyone
like you weren't allowed to post
anything about renovating this is what
got me and i was like okay i need a
different way to
find friends you couldn't post anything
about renovating
because you needed a trigger warning
first like i got in trouble for asking
about renovations
because it was triggering two people who
couldn't afford renovations oh it was
like my god
at what point yeah at least with like at
least with something like an eating
disorder like
a lot of the people who have one are
gonna be pretty
uh for lack of a better word neurotic
like a lot of people with health any
type of health problem are neurotic
um so at least with the trigger warnings
there it's like
you know you know people could say
you're not trying to not trigger a binge
or something
um so like i've got some compassion
there but yeah you need some sort of
exposure
therapy right because you're talking
about being able to listen to these
conversations and things without
being worried that it's going to make
you sick right that's exactly 100
it's i think i think of course there's
there's there's compassion there for
for i mean the nature of eating
disorders they're they're brutal
but um but also yeah i think if you
can't hear
conversations about it there's no hope
you've got to face the reality of it
good bad and ugly and also this book
called intuitive eating that was that
was really helpful
i've heard about that it's really great
does that does that tell you what to eat
or just
like how does that work doesn't go into
what at all it's just about um
it's just about going back to the kind
of almost like a child's
point of view toward food where it's
like you eat when you're hungry
um and you stop when you're full and you
eat you know three meals a day like your
parents aren't going to let you go by
not eating a meal so you get it you got
to make sure that you you stay on top of
eating three times a day
and it sounds so basic saying that kind
of overall premise of the book
but it really breaks it down in such a
way that's like oh
you can kind of start to unlearn your
patterns and
and be ex for me it was like being
re-exposed to oh
this is what like normal eating is and
also
this like i i'm i'm rambling because i
care i
care very much about like helping in any
way that i can people with eating
disorders i just think they're such a
waste of time i think they
take so much potential out of people and
it's like heartbreaking to me that
there's all these people out there who
could be so much more but they're just
wasting their time on this addiction
that's like defeating that it's just it
it's so bothersome um but but uh
not having any food rules i think is
really important as well if there's a if
there's anything you can do
because as soon as you got one role oh
i'm just gonna do no what
unless you have to for health reasons of
course or just the conversation have
with your doctor
but for me it was like as soon as i had
one food rule then i had
a hundred and then i was just oh well
it's just lettuce cool
great you know it's a very slippery
slope
yeah yeah i see that i had um i was on
ssris for a very long time and they made
me
excessively i didn't know at the time
until i stopped taking them but they
made me excessively hungry like
i felt like i was starving all the time
um
and i actually managed to get that well
not taking the drug really helped
um but i found managing my appetite
becoming more restrictive actually
worked for me
um but i went i mean i didn't do it for
you know i didn't have an eating
disorder i don't think i would qualify
it as that
but it definitely managed my hunger
better i think
um not eating so many tasty things
because i had like
zero self control i don't know if anyone
has very good self control around like
cinnamon toast crunch but
it helped cutting those things for me so
interesting
i've done i've done i've looked into
like your story quite a bit and
seeing your kind of history with health
and your your health
journey it's so the opposite of
what mine is like it's the things that
are literal like nose
for for eating disorders i know and i
think that's also that's
important to to understand because i
think i think that can be confusing for
people they're like well wait a second
how come can't i cut out a thing can't i
whatever and it's like well it's
different if there's eating disorders
involved
then what might actually be good for you
if it's just like a health
yeah i think i think the best way to
handle these things i haven't like i've
got a couple of
facebook groups and support groups for
people going through like chronic
illnesses and i've had people
with eating disorders recover but i
think that also
might have something to do with nutrient
malabsorption problems
because i think there's something there
too so i think the eating disorders
you know from stress extreme stress
or are in a different category than
people who
have an eating disorder because they're
having
malabsorption problems and generally
you really have to figure out what's
good for your own body
right like yeah you really have to i
think what really got me healthy was i
started
listening to what my body was saying yes
i'd been ignoring it
and so maybe the intuitive eating thing
maybe it was
partly just teaching yourself pay
attention to what's going on inside
pay attention to when you're hungry pay
attention hundred percent not
hungry right like and that
that's really hard lots of people lose
track of that like even people who
wouldn't
say they have an eating disorder a lot
of people lose track of
when they're full even when they're
hungry
yeah so it's like you kind of rob
yourself of your body cues
you're so used to the addictive thinking
that there's no
genuine body awareness or for me there
was was absolutely
none yeah i i had an issue with
because i'd been in pain for a lot of my
life i was ignoring some of these things
or if you're
you know cripplingly depressed then you
kind of ignore
you learn to ignore cues especially if
you're told to
that it's the right thing to do it's
like oh that's not important you know
excessive daytime sleepiness oh it's
normal everybody has it so you kind of
put that into the category of things
that you ignore and then by the time for
me by the time
i was like 23 i had like 16
health symptoms that i was ignoring so
what
other than your podcast you said you
wrapped up you wrapped up season one
you're working on season two uh and you
said you wanted to get into directing so
what what's your plan for the future
i i've directed so many short films in
the past
and uh now i'm working on features
um i've done the whole like film
festival thing and and
done that whole spiel but now i'm i'm
writing two features
and uh hoping fingers crossed hoping to
do something
with those and then the one woman show
i'd love to get back to
whenever possible i imagine i imagine
relatively soon uh yeah i'm thinking
next summer
right that seems promising that's kind
of what i'm aiming for
yeah that's my guess i'd love to for
like professional and personal reasons
it's just like such a personal story and
talking about that like i yearn for that
closure of doing it again and like
having there be there's something about
like art that's just like okay i can put
an end to this thing that there was
really no
end to in it's such a nebulous like
life weird trauma thing that like i can
at least
find the story in it and move on from it
in as much as i can
by doing that thing and uh so i look
forward to doing it again for that
reason
yeah i get that i have this i told you
this book i've been
working on and it has a sense of like
you know being chronically ill is
totally traumatizing
you're aware of that like so there's a
lot and it's nice to
kind of like you said put an end to it
and art does allow you to do that kind
of thing
for me it's this book but performance
too
when is your book coming up i'm so
excited oh my god i'm hoping
late next year awesome we'll see
that's what i'm hoping but i will
definitely be letting everybody know
uh thank you so much for coming on uh
it was very nice to e-meet you
thanks for having me i i really i enjoy
talking to you some i really really
enjoy our conversations yeah that was
fun
yeah i'm i'm a little bit i don't know
like not to be insulting i'm a bit
surprised i don't usually you know get
along with people too easily
uh surprising is that surprising i don't
know how surprising that is but i don't
so
that was very fun um where where can
people find you online
other than just typing in jeanette
mccurdy um yeah my website's
jeanette mccarty.com but my name spelled
weird to the point that like my uncle
still misspells it so i'll spell it out
it's d
n n e t t e m c c u r d y
genetically dot com takes at everything
but i'm also on every social media
platform there is i won't name them
because
the list is too long at this point
there's like 12 of them
can't keep up there's a lot yeah okay
well
thank you very much for coming on and
we'll keep in touch for sure
great i'll hope to see you someday in
person
to do those shrooms definitely
all right bye thanks for watching
remember to rate and subscribe if you
enjoyed the episode and remember to use
code mp
for 15 off at selfauthoring.com and
understandmyself.com thanks for watching
[Music]
you